hey everyone I'm a Leica I'm gonna talk
to you today about colorism in
high-fashion and more specifically how I
was able to explore this issue using a
bunch of different open-source Python
libraries that probably you guys have
heard of before
so before I jump into the technical
details I do want to give you a little
crash course in sort of racism in
fashion just so that we're all on the
same page there there's three things
that I want to talk about so the first
is just the idea that fashion is super
white especially in America and we can
see a great example of that with Vogue
magazine a really iconic fashion
magazine vogue literally means fashion
and French they've been around since
1892 and it wasn't until 1974 so 80
years later that they put a black woman
on the cover they were making weekly
issues at the beginning and then they
transitioned to monthly issues and and
it still took over 80 years so this is
Beverly Johnson and she was talking in
an interview about what it meant for a
model to appear on the cover of Vogue
and she says this is our Oscar this is
our gold medal this is everything in the
industry so you really can't overstate
how important how much of a milestone it
is for a model to make it onto the cover
of Vogue and it took 80 years before
that door was open to black women so the
next two things I want to talk about
have to do with colorism colorism is
this idea what so we have racism which
is prejudice against people of color and
then colorism takes that a step further
and it's the idea that there is further
prejudice against people of color with
dark skin when you compare to people of
color with light skin and you see this
in a lot of different communities around
the world you see this in Southeast Asia
and East Asia you also see it in the
black and Latina community to the point
where women will will bleach their skin
lighter took to conform to that beauty
standards so if we if we look at zendaya
this really popular actress and model
you might know her from spider-man or
from tens
other things she has light-skinned and
she talks about how she thinks part of
the reason she was able to become so
successful was because she was sort of
lucky enough to be born just conforming
to this beauty standard and she's very
open about that in an interview she said
I'm Hollywood acceptable version of a
black girl and that has to change so we
can talk about colorism and one other
way as well
post-processing so this is two photos of
this actress Aishwarya Bachchan and you
can see that on the magazine cover
she looks significantly lighter right
her skin has been adjusted so that she
looks lighter and when this magazine
cover came out I think it was in 2010
people were really surprised they were
sort of like we know what you look like
like we've seen you before and your skin
isn't this color and she was also
surprised because this decision was made
without her the the photographers and
the editors l decided that when she was
on their cover they wanted her to look a
certain way they wanted her to look very
white and they made that decision
without her and so that's something else
that we see is the use of photoshopped
to lighten images um when I think about
these issues of inequality and Prejudice
I immediately look at them through the
lens of data science and I think a lot
of you probably do as well I sort of
look for ways to talk about this that
use statistics or visualizations ways
that will that will sum up this issue
and when we look at the first aspect the
idea that fashion is really white it's
pretty easy to get some stats from there
I mean it's been done before so there's
this piece called the Great Awakening
what they did is for their six magazines
here but they did this for actually I
think twelve magazines they counted the
number of covers which had a non-white
subject and then they were able to graph
this so what they're showing is
basically in the past few years there's
been a huge uptick in the number of
non-white subjects on a magazine cover
and this they were they gathered the
data really well I really encourage you
to check out this piece but they are
missing some of the subtleties of
colorism this address
racism but it doesn't tell us about how
those non-white subjects look they could
all just sort of be Hollywood's
acceptable version of a non-white
subject and that's lost here so I wanted
to talk about colorism in a quantitative
way and to be clear people talk about
colorism a lot here's a Alexander Acacio
Cortez she's a congresswoman here in New
York and when she was photographed on
the cover of Time magazine
she actually thanked the photographer
for getting her skin tone right in the
photo she said it's the little things
that make a big difference a lot of
people see and appreciate it
so this is an ongoing conversation that
you see a lot especially on social media
and there are a lot of pieces about this
but I felt that quantitative data was
missing from this conversation and
that's something that I felt that I was
I was be able to contribute that and and
when you're looking for sort of a
personal project or something you want
to do when you don't feel like working
on your homework in college um I would
suggest that you look for an issue that
that matters to you and maybe that issue
is missing quantitative data and maybe
that's something that you can add to the
conversation cool so I worked on this
with a publication called the pudding
they do a lot of super great visuals and
data journalism I really encourage you
to check them out and for this project
we decided to look at just vogue
magazine we felt it was super
representative of fashion and that sort
of we were able to look at how things
change over time because they're issues
and so we came up with this research
question like how do you turn a
photograph of a woman's skin in this
case the cover photo of Vogue how do you
turn that into a number and this is a
really hard question like I sort of sat
with this question for a while and
didn't have an answer so I decided to
replace it with a question that I did
know the answer to so I could feel like
I was making some progress there so and
that question is how do you turn a color
into a number and this is something we
all are sort of familiar with um like if
you've used matplotlib or like updated
the HTML on your Neopets page you
probably know Rajee RGB color
representation so you take a color and
you're able to represent it with numbers
and RGB is it is probably
the most common quantitative
representation of color but it's not the
only one one that I used was called HSL
so it stands for hue saturation
lightness and the lightness value will
range from 0 to 100 or 0 to 1 depending
on how you scale things and a lighter
value a higher value indicates that the
color is lighter and a lower value
indicates that the color is darker so
there's this question answered like if
we have a single color how do we turn
that into a number that represents how
light a woman is well we just convert it
to HSL we import some Python library
that'll do that for us and that's fixed
so now we can go back to to this more
complicated question so so we're working
with a skin tone right not a single
color and a skin tone has a lot of
colors within it like if we look at this
this picture of Daisy Ridley we can sort
of zoom in on different parts of her
skin and it'll return to us different
colors like if we look at her forehead
then we get this sort of beige if we
look at maybe her cheek where there's
more makeup then we get this pink or we
could look at the shadow of her chin and
we'll get this dark brown so her skin
tone contains lots of different colors
within it and it's not obvious which one
we're going to use when we're talking
about converting this to HSL and taking
the lightness value what we want is sort
of a way to summarize her entire skin
tone and that's again a tricky question
but what you can do is you can you can
zoom in really far on this picture you
know like you're in a cop show and
you're like enhance and and when you
zoom in all the way then you get
something that looks like this you reach
sort of the building blocks of an image
the pixel representation and each one of
these cells each one of these pixels
does have its own single distinct color
value and here they're represented in
RGB and when you're working with images
the like all sorts of libraries I use
open CV but pretty much any library that
you're going to use is going to read an
image in like this a 3 dimensional array
so two of the dimensions are to sort of
capture that it's a rectangle and then
the third dimension is this this inner
list with three elements the RGB color
values so Bo
I was talking about summarizing the skin
tone of a model and that's it that's a
tricky question but if I ask a roomful
of data scientists to summarize a list
of numbers you will all know the answer
to that so we can take the pixels that
represent her skin and this is just a
list of numbers and how do we sort of
summarize that we take the average so
you can take the average and it'll give
us back a 3-tuple
and that that three tuple is itself a
color and so now we've we've been able
to summarize her skin tone into a single
color and we have this workflow that's
developed so we start with a we've got
Rihanna here to demo the workflow for us
we start with an image of a woman this
comes from the cover of Vogue and we
grab all of the pixels that represent
her skin then we average these to get a
single summery skin tone we can convert
that to HSL and then we sort of ignore
the hue and the saturation components
like those aren't really relevant to us
so we end up with this the single number
that represents how light Rihanna is in
this image that was on the cover of
Vogue cool um so I did sort of skip a
pretty important step here I don't know
if you noticed but when I'm when I was
looking at this array and I wanted to
take all of the all of the pixels or all
of the cells that represented skin I
just sort of clicked and dragged them
because there there's only 20 data
points here and and the images I was
working with had a lot more than 20
pixels in them they were generally a 500
by 500
so about 250,000 pixels and I didn't
really want to be if sort of sitting in
my room all day tagging these pixels by
hand I had some more interesting things
to do with my life
so so what I want is something like this
right where every pixel comes with a
label some are labeled as skin and some
are label does not skin and then I can
filter out the ones that are skin and
I'll use just those images or just those
pixels when I'm calculating my summery
skin too so this is sort of the dream
and what we've got here if we squint a
little bit and we look at this sideways
um we have as 20 data points and each
data point has some numerical features
that are associated
with it and each data point has a label
that's associated with it and I want to
use those features to predict the label
so you can see where I'm going with this
this is just a machine learning problem
and and that's that's even more evident
when I when I organize the data points
into a table like this we can see our
three feature columns and then we can
see our label column and the nice thing
about having the data in this tabular
form is that then we can do a little bit
of exploratory data analysis like we all
know and love like I can plot these
points in a three dimensional space
because there are three features and
I've colored each one to sort of remind
you of what these these numbers
represent here and you can see that they
split really easily into two clusters
and that sort of that bodes well this is
a great signal that I'm receiving that
this this seems like a solvable problem
I'm going to be able to predict which
things lie in which cluster and that
seems pretty doable so one of one aspect
of this data that's a little bit wrong
in this representation is here I've got
listed the label and in reality I was
dealing with totally unlabeled data
I didn't sort of go through and tag a
few pictures to get training data there
are no labels at all so it's a totally
unsupervised problem and what we've got
here is is a set up that matches k-means
clustering really well so raise your
hand if you've heard of k-means
clustering yes okay cool
raise your hand if you like know the
math behind k-means clustering okay
well we'll fix that today so the sort of
ideal problem set up for k-means
clustering is these these bullet points
you have some data points so here one
data point is one pixel in an image and
each image is going to be treated as its
as its own individual data set then we
have some categories so here the
categories that we care about our skin
and not skin and so those are the two
labels that we're trying to end up with
then each data point belongs in one of
the categories so this is really cut and
dry like we want every pixel to end up
totally sorted we don't want any sort of
maybe pixels here and then the last
thing is we have no access to tagged
data and that's what
earlier so before I sort of dive into
the the math behind communes which I'm
sure you're all super excited for I do
want to emphasize one thing um this is
the data set that I started out with
when I came up with this project a data
set of the the models who have been on
the cover of Vogue magazine and I had
this information about them like their
name the date that they appeared on the
cover their race a few other things
we tracked I think the photographer as
well and what what my final goal was is
to add a numerical column to this data
set
which would be the lightness value and
that would be a single number ranging
between 0 and 100 or 0 & 1 depending on
on how I scale things so when I'm using
k-means I'm not using k-means on this
data set I'm using k-means on a
different data set so each row becomes
its own data set like if we look at
Renee Zellweger here this photo of her
is my new dataset and it is like a table
with three features and a label that I
went to predict and I fit a k-means
model to it I record that information
and then I totally garbage collect that
k-means model I don't keep it around for
anything then I move on to the next row
and this is Julianne Moore and she gets
her own k-means model as well and so in
the end I ended up fitting about 250
different k-means models because every
single cover girl got their own one this
is I really just want to be very clear
about this because when we're talking
about machine learning and image
processing and people of different races
there's a lot of bias there and and we
can talk about that all day but but
something that crops up is you'll see
people training models on images that
look a certain way like maybe only white
people and then they'll try and use
those models to predict things about
people who look a different way and
that's a very important issue but it's
not something that I was dealing with
here because my model wasn't it wasn't
sort of remembering information from
training data and trying to apply those
patterns elsewhere there is a new
camions model for every single image
that I was dealing with cool so let's go
into k-means a little bit and we're
going to use Amal Clooney as
people here so what I did here is I
sampled about a thousand pixels from
this image randomly and I plotted them
in two dimensions so here red and blue
and that's just because two dimensions
is a lot easier to look at on a screen
than three dimensions and so the way
k-means works is you're going to start
with two centers so here they've been
randomly initialized another way that
k-means will do it is it'll select two
data points from the data set and I'll
use those as starting centers this works
better for sort of this this explanation
so then what happens is every single
point calculates two distances and two
because there are two centers so it
calculates the distance to the red
center and the distance to the blue
center and then whichever is closer it
gets assigned to that category so if we
do that for every point then we end up
with something like this and now we
reset so we so we take all of the red
points and we average them together and
that's our new red center and we do the
same with the blue points so that'll
look something like this and then we
just iterate through this a lot so we so
we iterate and we we reassign the
center's and then we reassign the points
and we do this a few times and there's
usually there's usually some sort of
stopping criteria like maybe it'll be a
thousand iterations or something like
that to get you to converge to a point
where every one of these data points so
in this case every one of these pixels
gets assigned to a category and in this
case the categories are skin and not
skin so um I fit my very first k-means
model and this is this is what I ended
up looking like so this is using red
green and blue values as the features
and there are two clusters skin and not
skin and what I did is I went through
and for every pixel in the image if it
was sort of tagged as not skin then I
painted it light blue and if it was
tagged as skin then I kept it the same
color and so this is this was sort of my
metric for measuring how well k-means
was doing is I would just look at this
image and be like yeah that's pretty
good
and so I this is one of the first images
I looked at when I had fit this first
model and I was I was super excited
about it and then I was like look I've
done it I've created the perfect skin
detector um and then I started looking
at some more images and it doesn't
always work that
so this is again a new k-means model
that was fit using red green and blue
and using three using two clusters and
then I looked at some more and it was
doing I mean here it's doing like a
pretty bad job it's missing a lot of her
skin
it's including her teeth and like the
whiteness of her shirt so so not a great
model here and and what I did is that I
sort of thought back to to how to do the
best ever machine learning and and the
way you do the best ever machine
learning is you start with an initial
model which I have my RGB with two
clusters and you look at the metrics to
see how it performed so it was doing
okay in some places and did not so great
in other places and then you do a little
bit of tuning you adjust the features
you adjust the hyper parameters and you
sort of rinse and repeat and what if you
do this enough times then at the end you
have the perfect model right and that's
just how you do machine learning so in
this case my my features I started with
RGB and I expanded them to also include
HSL I played around with using the
distance a pixel was from the center of
a photo the idea was that skin is sort
of concentrated in the center of a photo
because faces are round and the in the
image is square but that didn't super
work so I ended up cutting that then for
Hyper parameters k-means is really nice
because there is exactly one hyper
parameter and it is the number of
clusters so my original idea was to use
two clusters on four skin and not skin
but what I found is in a lot of images
there would be sort of three natural
clusters there would be the skin the
hair and the makeup you can see that
with Amal Clooney's graph like there's
the light brown then there's the block
and then there's the red which comes
from her lipstick and her earrings and
if you imagine this in three dimensions
the three clusters are are even more
prominent and so I fit I sort of looked
at these and I fit another model and my
the next model that I tried was I used
just red because humans have a lot of
red and their skin tone so I thought
that would help and I used three
clusters to account for the makeup and
again like it worked it worked really
well with Nicole Kidman and then there
were a few
it didn't do that great of a job like
here it's saying that that the text in
the background that n that comes from
the cover it's saying that that skin and
I didn't like that at all and then there
was somewhere it was just a mess what
what have they done to go in at the
polisher here so I was like okay well
I'm just gonna I'm stuck in this
iterative loop right okay so I'm gonna
like do some more feature engineering
change the features up change the hyper
parameters again and we do this again
and again and I've got this really nice
function where if I just tell it what
features to use then it'll save all
these images for me um and I got very
stuck in that loop and I ended up
fitting 14 different combinations of
these k-means models so so for a single
image I would have something like this
and one night I was looking at all of
these panels of images so I ended up
with about 250 of these panels one for
each cover girl and I was like I can
look at this and I know which models are
doing a bad job right like these are
doing these are performing really poorly
and it takes me one second to decide
that and I can also see which models are
doing a good job right like that's doing
a really good job of getting her skin
and I know that I can just look at it
and I know that and I was like I wish
there was some way where instead of
automating all of this like I am a human
who knows things and I want to
contribute that knowledge and it turns
out I'm totally allowed to do that
nothing there's no one telling me that
everything had to be perfectly automated
I just sort of got stuck in that because
I think when we talk about machine
learning a lot there's this gold
standard of like we want to remove
humans from the process we want this
this perfectly automated pipeline we
just run it we never check in at all and
things like work really really great and
and that had been so like burned into my
brain that that was what I was focused
on and and my problem wasn't that I
wanted to create the perfect skin
detector remember like that was never my
research question at all my problem was
that I wanted to get 250 different
lightness values for 250 different cover
girls I like why not use a human to help
do that so this is something called
human and the loot machine learning and
you see
you see it in a few different places one
place that it's really common is on
forums where there's a lot of comments
and maybe some of the comments aren't
very nice there will be a machine
learning algorithm that Flags some
comments for review and it doesn't make
a decision about whether to banned that
user or to delete that comment but it
pushes those comments towards an admin
and then that human will look at it and
make a decision and so that's sort of
what we ended up doing so for this this
panel of images Mia and an intern who
worked at the the publication of the
pudding we looked at these panels and
then we decided like okay this one is
good sometimes there'd be more than one
sometimes there'd be like this one is
good as well and we took these images
and that's what we used for the skin and
we averaged her and my results together
so that there things wouldn't be sort of
skewed to my opinions and so that was
how we were able to turn a photograph of
a woman's skin into a number we used
k-means to fit a ton of different models
humans went through and sort of
double-checked that the models were
doing a good job we extracted the skin
as just a list of numbers and created a
summary skin tone we converted that to
HSL and snagged the lightness value from
that and then we were able to make some
plots so here we've got a bee swarm plot
this was made by Jan and ever at the
putting they're absolutely lovely to
work with a piece where pot is sort of
like a more granular histogram like it's
still one-dimensional but in a histogram
we summarize things into bars and here
we leave the individual data points so
we've got lightness on the x-axis and
and we and then each point is sort of
stacked so you can see where they tend
to lie and the colors are that summary
skin tone that I talked about earlier so
when you look at this graph it's pretty
clear that Vogue does not put
dark-skinned women on their cover of
their magazine this is 20 years and I
think anyone can look at this graph and
say there were two or maybe there were
four dark-skinned women on the cover of
Vogue and that's very clear and very
obvious here but I think that when you
read a think piece or something like
that about colorism maybe you'll connect
to it and then it'll it'll have this
impact on you and and you'll realize
they're saying but maybe it won't and I
think that you don't need to connect
with this graph at all to know what it's
saying it's pretty clear what it's
saying
I mean it's saying that like vote needs
to do a better job and with a lot of
fashion magazines it's the same way so
another thing that we looked at is this
data over time so here's a time series
and you can see this sort of fan shape
as we get to as we get to closer years
we did this up to 2018 and so that sort
of suggests that things are improving
like the range is widening they've got
some some people with darker skin
they've got people with super light skin
as well and so maybe this is like a
change and and we sort of dove into this
very excitedly and we found that what
happened was they put Lupita Nyong'o on
the cover four times she was in she was
in 12 years a slave and a lot of other
things very recently and so if we remove
here from this graph then there is no
fan shape at all so there's actually no
change over time um this is something
that's called tokenism and if you check
out the the article that we ended up
writing we go a lot more into depth
about that but the idea is sort of we
thought that that vote had started
putting dark-skinned women on their on
their cover and actually what they did
is they found one dark-skinned woman
that they liked and they just sort of
used her over and over again and that's
really that's that's really not okay at
all and that's that's not a good
solution to this problem a solution
would be to find a lot of dark-skinned
women and put them on the cover and and
so that's what I was able to show by
sort of bringing quantitative data into
this pretty qualitative topic thank you
should I pass it on the mic for
questions yeah
then I will not have a mic no flutters
hello hi and sociologists we're gonna
design this I greatly appreciate your
work
I think we're relevant and so looking at
your work so race is a very complicated
thing right you know it's skintone in
one sense they're sauces like culture
hair etc etc including assumptions about
you know what sir who's gonna do it
right so they say yeah that would say
blacks are more athletic and whites are
listening local Asian or whatever with
that in mind that I'm reminded of Ashley
mirrors work so she does sociology
fashion very very smart man you should
say I want you but don't forget that and
she looks at sort of the high fashion
you know where you make no money but how
about the proceed and sort of like being
on the cover of like catalogs that has
no spirit proceeds but actually pays
bills yeah
and so I'm wondering if you extend this
analysis to look beyond high fashion if
you see sticker selling athletic
clothing hey you know darker skin people
were more you know prefer worse athletic
less put them on the cover to show like
a so there are there are two things that
I think are relevant to that question on
the first is the initial version of this
analysis it wasn't for vogue covers I
used the the models on the Gucci website
and the models on the American Eagle
website so two very different clothing
brands one is very like fast casual and
one is very high-fashion and I looked at
the differences there and what happened
was basically Gucci had this very
bimodal distribution where they would
only have super light-skinned or super
dark-skinned women to sort of get that
like exaggerated effect that you see a
lot in high fashion and an American
Eagle it was a very smooth curve where
they wanted to to sort of get someone of
every skin tone another thing is if we
look at this this plot so these these
four points
to where the pizza and the other two
were Serena Williams and Michelle Obama
and so we looked at sort of people who
are on the cover who are models versus
people who are on the cover because they
are famous and a lot of the black women
who are on the cover were there because
they were famous as opposed to because
they were famous models and so that was
a distinction we noticed as well
I'm sorry I already explained this but
how did you crop the basis of a newer
standard at the side did you do that but
you just have the intern to that manual
err yeah so I left out a few of the
details about pre-processing because
they were pretty boring um one thing I
did was I removed the background of the
images using this tool it's called
remove be removed BG or something um and
actually this neural nuts to identify
humans and then it wipes out the
background and then I also use just very
standard like out-of-the-box open CV to
do facial recognition to crop those
images down to says and the facial
recognition that was more like human in
dilute machine learning like I checked
there were a ton of false positives that
I had to like delete and get rid of that
those were the two types of
pre-processing that I did thanks lips
natural that easy skin color so that was
something that was something else that
was that was more qualitative is when we
were looking at like panels like this we
when it was like very aggressive makeup
and we felt that that camions had even
classified it as not skin then that was
a pretty pretty good indicator
if it matched more their natural tone
then we were more likely to like to let
it slide
yeah
experiences in some cases
leaders each active
so I got a question about repeat models
so that's good we unlock via the bonus
slides so here's Rihanna as she was on
the cover five times a really cool thing
about her is her like like lightness
ranges from zero to one and her
lightness values spend like the range of
0.5 like they vary that much across the
covers if you check out the the article
which I will I have a link to it here or
you can just google that colors on the
high fashion um we have like a tool
where you can explore how different
models are represented on the cover
I think Beyonce was on there a lot and
also Giselle was on there like seven
times and you can see that I mean
generally women of color were
photographed very differently and white
women were photographed pretty similarly
I have thought about use cbcr
instead of H hue and lightness sinned
against in cbcr is like so I looked at a
few different ways to represent color um
I don't I didn't look into the one that
you mentioned but I did look into um
I think it's CMYK or something um and
that wasn't really capturing what I
wanted look I wanted the lightness value
then also when fitting the k-means
models
I tried use fitting the model using like
just lightness or using just hue which
is sort of akin to like the shade and
some of those before while at some of
this didn't also if there's no other
questions that this link contains a link
to my github so you can see like the
code that was used to fill out these
models well thank you so much your cut
[Applause]